السلطات التركيه اليوم قالت اكثر من 1400
هزار ارتداديه وقعت منذ وقوع الكارثه
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وقد وقع في منطقه شديده الزلازل هذه
المنطقه هي واحده من اخطر المناطق في
البحر الابيض المتوسط الجزء الاوسط
الجنوبي من تركيا كان الاكثر تضررا كما
تشاهدون ووزاره النقل والبنيه التحتيه
التركيه تعتقد ان اجمالي
1275 كيلومترا من خطوط السكك الحديد قد
تضررت بشكل خطير من الزلزال الذي ضرب
منطقه كارما مراش وفي اشاره الى التغييرات
في خط الصدى بعد الزلزال لفت البروفيسور
كارلو دودجليوني رئيس المعهد الوطني
الايطاليه للجيو فيزياء والبراكين ان
زلزله تركيا تسبب في تحول جيولوجي ادى الى
تحريك الواح الغلاف الصخري بمقدار ثلاثه
وهذا يعني ان تركيا تحركت من مكانها ثلاثه
امتار ووفقا للعالم الايطالي حدث كل شيء
في عشرات الثواني ويبدو الامر كما لو ان
تركيا قد تحولت الى الجنوب الغربي